tiens mariani la biélorussie c'est
l'autre grand chapitre qui concerne
l'union européenne puisque c'est à ses
portes qui a fait l'objet de sanctions
puisque l'élection ne foutent du
président lukashenko est mise en cause
par l'ensemble des dirigeants européens
qui disent qu'elle n'est pas régulière
alors vous reconnaissez ce président est
ce qu'il ne tient que grâce à vladimir
poutine
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
on s'aperçoit que l'élection en bélarus
est contesté par une part semble-t-il
majoritaire du peuple du bélarus la
question c'est comment on sort de cette
situation avec un président qui s'est
proclamé qui est décidé à rester et une
partie de la population qui est décidé à
le renverser
je pense une fois de plus pas en votant
des sanctions en décidant tout seul que
mal un petit anneau sky a été lu il ya
un autre précédent depuis que ce qui est
le venezuela depuis que je siège au
parlement européen depuis que nous
siégeons au parlement européen puisque
nous avons été élus ensemble il ya un an
nous pensons quand même en même temps si
vous voulez en même temps je vous
rassure
en réalité je crois qu on en est à la
septième résolution est au 11e débat sur
le venezuela et au vote des résolutions
en demande 10 ans le vrai président
c'est guido et donc il faut changer de
président je crains qu'au bélarus en se
soient mis exactement dans la même
impasse
c'est à dire au lieu de faciliter un
dialogue entre les deux blocs
que dit l'union européenne elle a dit
tout de suite monsieur loukachenko n'est
plus président le président désormais
ses manières mais qu'elle avait raison
je vous invite à lire le rapport parce
que tant de temps il faut lire les
rapports qu'on vote
elle dit tout simplement si on regarde
la plate forme de sondage madame
tikhonov sky a été élue présidente
c'est original est donc désormais
l'union européenne ne reconnaît pas
monsieur lukashenko reconnaît alain
petit canot sky à résultat aujourd'hui
en est exclue du dialogue ce qu'il
fallait dire quand on était prêt à dit à
faciliter un dialogue entre les deux
avant de dire que l'un ou l'autre avait
gagné bernard guetta c'est 100 je brosse
bnl ne servent à rien contre je peux
régime de location comme aux non elles
ne servent pas rien du tout parce que
les comportements aussi inadmissible que
monsieur leucan tchenko doivent être
d'autant plus sanctionnés que l'union
européenne apporte une aide économique
et financière
à la biélorussie alors évidemment que
nous devons pas continuer à apporter
cette aide à un régime un président
sortant qui vient de se comporter de
cette manière les temps mais vladimir
poutine soutient le kent qu il reste
indéboulonnable
alors écoutez ce que monsieur poutine
soutient monsieur le cash and co
aujourd'hui je dirais qu il le soutient
du bout des lèvres vous avec des
pincettes et je pense pour ma part je je
m'y emploie pour l'instant sans nom
jeudi avec un succès mais un succès très
relatif je pense que l'union européenne
aujourd'hui devrait envoyer des
intermédiaires des go between à monsieur
poutine
en tout cas à l'entourage de monsieur
poutine pour lui ai dit écoutez nous
avons déjà vous et nous le problème de
l'ukraine
on ne peut pas ajouter le problème de la
biélorussie au propre modem ukrainiens
sans risquer une véritable
déstabilisation du continent européen
qui ne serait ni votre intérêt ni notre
intérêt ni l'intérêt est évidemment
d'aucuns citoyens européens de quelques
pays qu'ils soient alors monsieur
poutine
essayons de réfléchir ensemble aux
moyens d'éviter l'ukrainien nation de la
biélorussie je pense que dans quelques
semaines ou en tout cas quelques mois
monsieur poutine pourrait seraient
susceptibles d'entendre et de lâcher et
de lâcher finalement le cash and co
parce que ce président se prévaut du
soutien de moscou et des galeries son
soutien peut vraiment et ai dit que
c'est que dans ces conditions il n'a pas
besoin finalement de faire quoi que ce
soit contre une société civile qui les
répriment manifestation après
manifestation je crois que l'attitude le
grand gagnant de l'attitude européenne
ce avec la russie et si vous voulez en
sort on verra j'espère dans quelques
semaines et on verra qui a raison
quelle était la situation de monsieur du
bélarus en réalité le bélarus essayer
d'être à equities
ans entre la russie et l'europe et a
fait des gestes vis-à-vis de l'europe
etc
la russie essayant le vieux rêve
d'attirer le bélarus est de faire une
sorte de fédération avec le bélarus ici
à économiquement les liens sont plus
solides avec la russie uniquement
économiquement pas politiquement
l'indépendance monsieur loukachenko
justement politiquement et en est
aujourd'hui gelée d'irréel quel est le
dilemme aujourd'hui qu'à monsieur
lukashenko partir il se rapprocher de la
russie et je pense que on verra son
calvaire
objectivement il est allé rencontrer ben
oui oui bien sûr puisque deux façons
excusez moi l'europe et lui dit vous
n'avez aucune place vous devez partir
ben c'est forcément moi je vous dit vous
devez partir vous rapprocher des sols
qui sont prêts à discuter avec vous donc
je pense qu'on verra dans quelques
semaines peut-être que vous avez raison
peut-être que j'ai raison on verra mais
je pense que les grands gagnants une
fois de plus parce qu'ils ne pratiquent
pas la diplomatie j'allais dire moral
mais une diplomatie pratique ça risque
avec la russie qui attend gentiment que
rejetée par l'europe
monsieur loukachenko s'il résiste aux
grèves générales qui sont en cours en ce
moment où qui sont à répétition ça c'est
trop tôt pour le dire aujourd'hui mais
risque n'a plus aujourd'hui qu'un seul
choix partir ou se rapprocher de la
russie
[Musique]